ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
welt und meine lieben freunde wir haben
hier sieht bereits den titel
eingeblendet denn wir kümmern uns heute
endlich mal um die tier insel
die sind jetzt noch nicht so schön aus
das wird allerdings werden meine lieben
freunde und da freue ich mich extrem
drauf denn je nein keine sorge balu und
remix hier letztlich alle her
ihr fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich luca
hinten ist die tiere insel warum bist du
dann gerade hier das hat mir ganz
einfachen grund denn ihr kennt mich und
ich habe erst mal scharf es ist erstmal
gibt dass du mich anguckt bleibst auch
hier besteht
und freudigen dingen denn ich wollte den
weg hier ein erweitern so genau so wie
ich das hinter einem baumhaus gemacht
habe das finde ich ja auch dort hinten
ein bisschen schönen
sieht man jetzt gar nicht was ich
allerdings auch machen wollte war erst
mal ganz kurz das laves lazuli hier
komplett aus meiner kiste rausnehmen und
das ist wichtig weil man uns oder sagen
und wir können auch mal endlich wie auch
wir können auch mal endlich wieder den
witz baum aktiviertem opfer braucht man
keine witze erzählen denn du bist selber
einer
ja genau ich laufe mal ganz kurz eben
rüber zauberinsel denn ich habe mir
gedacht dass wir die ganzen lapislazuli
teile einfach mal hier rein packen dafür
auch noch mal ganz kurz diesem blog zur
bislang normal dass sie die mal wie viel
ich gefragt habe hinten in der höhle und
er kann mir damit demnächst ein bisschen
verzaubert falls der tipps habt schreibt
gern sehr sehr gern und in die
kommentare denn ich möchte wirklich
demnächst nicht mehr ein bisschen mehr
mit dem kompletten thema handel und
verzaubern auseinandersetzen hater und
der reflektion die zum wundervoll aus da
hinten kommt irgendwann auch noch der
leuchtturm hin die sache ist allerdings
dass das schon zwei der drei punkte sind
die ich bevor wir uns um die tiere
kümmern
abhaken wollte und der dritte punkt der
wurde mir glaube ich sogar auch in die
kommentare geschrieben und da jetzt
konnte ich allerdings bisher nicht
umsetzen da in den tests handvoll viele
items von mir drinnen mann
ich wollte die festlich abbauen da der
wille job bei mir hier oben im baumhaus
der ich schon ein bisschen auf der iss
halt fischer und der arbeits block vom
fischer sind fässer und deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht ich bau dir einfach ab
und bringen die fässer aber mal rüber
auf die willicher insel vielleicht hat
er ja boxe ich irgendwann bei
umzusiedeln und mich nicht immer zu
nerven nach vorne
in meiner bude deswegen hier einfach mal
einzelnen hier einziehen und hier kommen
auch noch einzeln setzten sieht jetzt
nicht so schön aus aber hoffentlich
schickt er dann dass das jetzt ein neues
haus sein wird ich hoffe auch dass hier
alles läuft
krempel mein ganzes feld kaputt müssen
allerdings erst mal jede menge sand
rausnehmen es benötigen wir alles und
den benötigen erde zum auffüllen von
löchern auf der insel was wir auch
benötigen sind eine menge blumen die
habe ich extra mitgenommen hinten aus
dem blumen biom darf ich wirklich eine
menge magie bieten hier auch noch
sonnenblumen also ganz ganz viel am
start
und was ich auch noch brauche sind
laternen ich weiß nicht mehr wo ich dir
eingepackt hatte ich glaube hier genau
sechs stück zu weit sind glaube ich zu
beginn das bereichen und ich war auch
noch eine menge stein ziegelmauern hier
vorne habe steine drin ziegelmauern habe
ich sogar noch 16 stück da kann ich mir
doch eigentlich noch ein paar mehr von
den laternen machen bzw
das inventar schon voll so viel sand
brauchen aber auch nicht ich würde euch
allerdings dennoch mal ganz kurz
einblenden die ich mich vorbereite
[Musik]
und da sind wir auch schon fertig meine
lieben freunde ich habe mich auf jeden
fall equity sieht schon in meinem
inventar ich habe mir alles mögliche mal
mitgenommen jedoch schon dass ich jetzt
in meinem boot noch keinen bewohner
meiner insel mitgenommen habe also weder
irgendwelche kür noch schildkröten was
weiß ich was wir haben hier vorne
wirklich überhaupt kein leben ich wollte
nämlich erstmal alles hier angucken
nicht dass er jetzt sehen wie aushöhlen
eingänge sind dann teil deiner mutter
und stirbt oder so ist sie brauche ich
nicht das kann man nicht komplett macht
zu bauen mit sand und jetzt nehme ich
hierfür noch ein bisschen erde und macht
dass hiermit auch ein bisschen schöner
so dass wir nicht hier plötzlich sand
oben haben davon habe ich allerdings
fast gar nichts mit dem wir gar nichts
mehr am start
deswegen müssen wir endlich noch mal
eben schnell rüber zu der erde insel ich
hoffe dass wir das hinkriegen bevor es
dunkel wird ich habe jetzt kein
reisebett mitgenommen allerdings euch
nochmal da auch eine ganz kurze time lab
so ihr seht schon dass ein neuer
sonnenaufgang hier gerade stattfindet
ein neuer morgen erwartet uns hier
unserer kleinen süßen welt ich parke
hier noch mal ganz kurz eben ihr habt
schon gerade in der tat gesehen ich habe
hinten wieder ein kleines löchlein
kreiert und mir eine menge her damit
genommen also zweieinhalb stacks sollten
auf jeden fall reichen ich möchte auch
dass hier nicht zu bauen das soll
bleiben der kleine sieht allerdings hier
vorne haben wir auch noch so eine kleine
lücke deswegen hoffe ich erst mal dass
es überhaupt nicht mit der ganzen erde
die ich mir gerade geholt habe was ich
auch mal ganz gut sagen wollte während
ich das jetzt alles zu bauen um euch
nicht jetzt schon nach ein paar minuten
die vierte teil selbst einzublenden
da die wahren risiken support kann ich
nicht oft genug sagen dass direkt zu
beginn ist geisteskrank dass jedes video
dieses projekt legen wie in den trend
ist und wie es bei euch einfach an kommt
das freut mich total und support auch
ohne euch wäre das projekt sind nicht
ansatzweise sogar jetzt gerade ist mit
euren tipps und so weiter und so fort
was sich allerdings auch sagen wollte
war das ist das heutige video wirklich
und ich weiß ist es so ein kleiner
running gag geworden aber das heutige
video wird wirklich kürzer als die
letzten part denn ich habe nach der
letzten aufnahme einfach gemerkt das ist
mir total schlecht ging ich habe total
spaß an der aufnahme und so weiter und
so fort safe guck mal wie schön das aus
privaten spenden
die sache ist allerdings ist mir ein
bisschen schwindelig war und das ist
glaube ich auch logisch wenn man vier
stunden am stück in summe 40 grad heißen
puma gebe ich hiermit licht an ein video
aufnimmt
deswegen möchte ich mich heute mal ein
bisschen zurücknehmen ich möchte das
video ein bisschen entspannter halt ein
bisschen mehr oldschool warum sagt man
eigentlich ist denn das ist das was wir
sonst machen new school als nicht also
nur für euch ganz kurz zu den für das
heutige video wird ein bisschen kürzer
als sonst und daran möchte ich mich auch
wirklich halten also dass wir vorne
erstmal der saison ein bisschen den
möchte ich mich so ein bisschen andeuten
ihr seht ja schon wie ich denn gerade
bauer
so sieht der finde ich ganz cool aus und
er sieht jetzt nicht so dass wir unser
sie da hinten allerdings behält auch
fast nie auf dieser tier insel hier sein
ich möchte die einfach nur haben damit
den tieren halt gut geht so ein bisschen
als belohnung für die tür weil jeder so
lange ausgehalten haben bei mir ist mit
dem strand hier finde ich irgendwie
nicht so schön gelöst das kann ich noch
mal ganz kurz eben weg machen eine
schaufel slider kaputt gegangen
erde farmen gerade da vorne
beziehungsweise ich werd ich noch nicht
komplett entfernen
mir wurde auch letztens in die
kommentare geschrieben luca wie sieht
eigentlich aus meinem strand um deine
villiger insel rum das ist halt ein
bisschen schwierig weil ich dafür da
drunter einfach ersetzen muss und das
weiß ich nicht ob ich das richtig
hinkriege die sache ist allerdings dass
wir hier jetzt eigentlich die insel
schon relativ schön haben klar hier
vorne so mit dem sand und so klar dass
wenn ich mich jetzt aber auch nicht
gerade darum kümmern weil real talk wir
sind die ganze zeit da wir sind nicht
hier was ich allerdings auf jeden fall
machen möchte ist eine menge mit blumen
arbeiten den stein hier brauche ich
nicht deswegen packe ich mir erstmal
ganz kurz die blumen hier rein und euch
dann nochmal ganz kurze time jetzt wie
ich die blumen hier hinsetzen
so sieht schon geil aus mit den blumen
und so also ich hab euch ja schon vom
hat folgen gesagt dass ich ja eigentlich
die blumeninsel dort vorne hin machen
wollte da wollte ich hier die erde
komplett runter ziehen so dass wir von
der strandhaus villa die auch demnächst
fertig sein wird und vor allem von
unserer insel manda hingucken können
allerdings sehe das nicht natürlich aus
wenn ich das darunter gezogen hätte
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht setze ich
die ganzen domizil in ihr seht schon ich
habe mir eine blume behalten das ist ein
löwenzahn ich glaube nicht dass das
damit funktioniert von dem ich mir jetzt
einfach mal so ein mond ich glaube damit
sollte es klappen
und zwar bot mir die kommentare
geschrieben luca es besteht eine 5
prozentige chance wenn du einen baum
wachsen lässt neben einer blume dass
dort ein wien lässt anstatt kommt
deswegen machen wir das jetzt einfach
mal so und vielleicht haben ja direkt
daran mit pech wir machen das jetzt mal
hier vorne meine lieben freunde wir
probleme mit der blume hier zeigt exakt
das hat nicht ganz geklappt wir
probieren es jetzt einfach mal hier
vorne nehmen sondern turbo oder dem zwei
bäumen vielleicht mal eine doppelte
chance das hat nicht geklappt wir machen
es jetzt mal hier vorne neben der hier
vielleicht klappt's ja ich habe aber
auch immer pech bei sowas
naja ich glaube noch mal ganz schön hier
drüber und pflanzen paar bäume so
wir haben hier jetzt alles voll gebaut
mit bäumen und ich finde so bäume oder
generell natur bringt so was wirklich
erst zum leben das sieht wirklich
wunderschön hier aus ich finde es fast
schon schön als unsere insel hinten weil
es hier auch ein bisschen größer ist ich
habe noch ein paar setzlinge übrig ich
würde allerdings auch nicht so zu
klatschen bzw
könnte man hier vorne nochmal sonnen was
können wir denn hin bauen noch mal eine
ak hat es hier vielleicht eine so können
wir noch mal hinsetzen perfekt der sieht
auf jedenfalls nicht so schön aus aber
das ist einfach mal so ich hab noch 17
knochen übrig deswegen werde ich jetzt
einfach mal so ein bisschen nochmal
darüber laufen und zumindest hier zur
seite wo wir immer hingucken alles noch
so ein bisschen verrückter machen
beziehungsweise gleich nachher natürlich
selbstverständlich es überall machen
aber soviel knochenmehl habe ich jetzt
gerade erst mal nicht mit ich musste
wegen der menge verschwinden für die
ganzen bäume und so wird das heißt
verschwenden also wir mussten ja
natürlich wachsen hier noch einmal zeit
hin und dann sehen wir schon die ganze
insel nimmt form an wir haben da vorne
auch ich weiß nicht ob wird das gerade
gesehen haben in der time lässt
allerdings haben wir schon die ersten
bewohner hier am start aber nicht wie
eine schildkröte
ich weiß nicht ob sie noch erzählt sie
schon hier gerade aktuell sieht es noch
nicht so heiß aus wir haben allerdings
noch hier vorne die steinige mauern drin
und laternen und ich möchte schon ein
bisschen ab und zu einfach sowas
hinsetzen so dass wir so ein bisschen
beleuchtung haben also ich werde jetzt
keine wege hin bauen die dann geleitet
werden von den stein ziegelmauern und
den laternen sowie das auf meiner insel
der fall ist allerdings möchte ich das
ganze halt so ein bisschen einfach
ausleuchten
ich weiß dass das nicht so viel bringen
wird wahrscheinlich gegen monster und so
weiter und so fort die werden trotzdem
hier spawnen weil wir einfach nicht so
viel alles ausleuchten können
es ist ja auf unserer insel auch schon
immer der fall dass da immer noch
creeper kommen und keine ahnung was
alles
obwohl wir alles mehr oder weniger
ausgeleuchtet haben also damit müssen
uns einfach ein bisschen abfinden ich
möchte allerdings dennoch dass es
zumindest bei nacht sie ein bisschen
schön aussieht so ein bisschen
beleuchtet und dann fehlt eigentlich
wirklich nur noch da die insel jetzt
eigentlich ein bisschen schöner aussieht
finde ich also ich weiß dass viele auch
immer sagen es macht keinen sinn das
soll schön klingen bleiben und so saß in
der verschiedene ansichten also ich
finde dass das extrem schön ist wenn man
einfach ja hier alles so ein bisschen
verbucht hat ein bisschen deswegen hier
noch ein hin und das reicht dann auch
erstmal mit der beleuchtung hier vorne
kommt natürlich noch knochen hin
die sache ist allerdings ist es für mich
erst mal ganz schön aussieht und genau
so habe ich mir das auch vorgestellt
deswegen kommen wir nun zum leben auf
der ganzen insel und dafür möchte ich
als allererstes einen werten kern holen
oder eine dame ist es glaube ich eine
werte dame holen die schon seit längerem
auf mich wartet
[Musik]
das habe ich habe es noch nie entdeckt
auf dem weg gehen
wir haben eine kiste wir sind jetzt
nicht so wertvolle sachen
ich vergesse immer dass ich unter wasser
nicht ab die sonne geht schon wieder
unter aber deswegen seht ihr auch schon
dass ich mir gerade noch ein weißes
reisebett mitgenommen habe aus meiner
auf einer insel wir haben hier vorne wir
haben tatsächlich wieder eine
schatzkarte drin als wir werden auf
jeden fall auch wieder einen schatz
heute finden meine lieben freunde bzw
ich hoffe dass wir den finden wenn man
die so gut darin wir haben hier
allerdings meistens ja immer noch wo
jetzt lebe ich habe auch am limit ich
baue mir hier mal ganz kurz eben die
kleinste base die es je gab in minecraft
und setzt jemand weißes brett hin bzw
werde mir auch erst mal ganz kurz ein
bisschen brot reinen snacken ganz kurz
vor euch zum verständnis meine insel
befindet sich dort ganz hinten also
nicht diese hier sondern weiter da
hinten und das dort wo wir hinfahren
befindet sich dorthin nirgendwo das
sieht man jetzt leider noch nicht am
horizont eingeblendet ich werde mich
aber ich bin halt ein früh schläfer
dankeschön
ich habe mich erst mal ganz gut schlafen
legen ich möchte auf jeden fall die
dritte kerze ja auch noch mitnehmen die
sich ja immer in den schiffen unten
befindet dafür mal ganz kurz die unsere
eisenachs genommen und untergetaucht ich
weiß nicht genau wo die dritte kiste ist
wir müssen uns das mal so vorstellen wo
würden wieder dritte kiste lagern wenn
wir pirat werden ich glaube
[Musik]
ich wäre auf jeden fall kein guter pirat
hh wir haben auf jeden fall noch einen
raum gefunden wir haben eine menge eisen
waren am start einen klumpen und la isla
das ist die echten kampf um leben und
tod noch mal ganz kurz neben den rest
geholt und jetzt können wir uns noch mal
ganz kurz die schatzkarte angucken das
ist auf jeden fall eine kleine insel auf
der sich der schatz befindet also es
könnte theoretisch wirklich dort hinten
irgendwo sein
wir haben allerdings erstmal anderes
ziel und das befindet sich dort hinten
jetzt sind wir direkt schon eingeblendet
es ist nämlich das winzerdorf meine
lieben freunde mir wurde so häufig in
den letzten folgen die kommentare
geschrieben luca roll bitte endlich das
schaf und ich weiß dass ich euch das
schuldig bin deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht es macht sinn das heute zu
machen denn wir machen ja heute geht
hier insel und ich habe eine ganz
besondere aufgabe für das schaf das
werde ich euch allerdings erst zeigen
wenn wir gleich bei der tier insel
angekommen sind also bleibt auf jeden
fall daran dass schaaf befindet sich wo
ist denn das
dass ich eigentlich hier vorne immer
gewartet ich dass das abgeholt oder so
wir haben auf jeden fall ein schwein wir
haben
[Musik]
wie geil ist das dass wir plötzlich hier
vorne die schatztruhe einfach gefunden
haben also die schatzkarte kann ich
dementsprechend mal hier lassen dass sie
nämlich mal ganz kurze mit die kohle bei
euch am abend bringen wir immer schöne
erfahrung für und jetzt konzentriert
allerdings wieder auf das
[Musik]
ist oben und dort auf dem berg oder was
ist das denn
es ist einfach nur die bergspitze ja und
deswegen nehme ich dich jetzt auch mit
und da habe ich auch extra das weizen
mitgenommen also komm her kommt da
hinten komplett abgebaut bis letztes
jahr schon 20 30 folgen ja egal wie er
will ich habe kein platz mehr
du kannst kein boot fahren egal wir
nehmen das schaf mit nicht dass jetzt
auch noch das trainieren fokussiert wird
oder so ich kann auch tatsächlich das
schaf mitnehmen weil ich einfach nicht
du kommst mit ihr hinter mir her ganz
langsam alles gut wir haben keinen
stress
alles easy so bleibt hier das schwein
haben schon schweinchen jo wetter hebt
ihre club sehr gut und jetzt ab ins
brötchen rhein mit dir perfekte super
wir sind im boot der regel sprechen eine
ganz kurze time labs dass wir uns gleich
auf der insel wieder sehen
guckt euch mal an wie schön diese tiere
insel hier einfach bereits aussieht das
ist wirklich sehr sehr geil da bin ich
sehr sehr stolz auf obwohl wie die tiere
die eigentlichen bewohner dieser insel
ja nicht mehr dort am start haben also
das schaf kommt hier hoch ich werde das
brötchen ganz kurz direkt wieder hier
rein setzen und mir hier meinen
namensschild nehmen das ist nämlich das
was ich machen möchte meine lieben
freunde das schaf hat ja wirklich locker
15 20 folgen lang dort ganz hinten auf
mich gewartet
deswegen möchte ich dem schaf hier den
vergeht das nicht ich muss das in den
amboss legen
das ist allerdings nicht weiter schlimm
denn die sonne geht gerade schon wieder
unter und ich bin meine aufnahme auch
schon anderthalb stunden das heißt es
gab wieder nicht mit einer kurzen
episode ihr seht schon wie schön das
hier bin ich wirklich sehr stolz auf
mein gott jetzt die kollision mit der
brücke ich werde ich jetzt mal ganz gut
zeigen was ich mir gedacht habe denn ich
möchte das namensschild im amboss
benennen zu
wenn ich das ja schon bürgermeister das
kostet sogar noch eine erfahrung und
damit möchte ich gleich rechts weg
machen auf das schäfchen ich glaube das
sollten wir sogar eventuell direkt noch
hinkriegen hier bevor die sonne
untergeht denn ich habe mir wirklich
gedacht mensch diese schaaf hat das so
lange in dem dorf gewartet und deswegen
soll es auch die erste person sein die
hier vorne auf unserer insel so richtig
ansiedeln darf klar die schildkröte
laufen
hat nicht auch nichts mehr dass er
plötzlich da war allerdings möchte ich
ihr dementsprechend die ehre geben die
dem schaf zuteil werden sollte und zwar
dass sie der bürgermeister ist
der scharf bürgermeister sehr passiert
so ein bisschen auf 74 oder näher ist es
ist noch immer wie schön die ganze natur
machen einfach so viel schöner ich würde
allerdings ganz gut sagen dass ich mal
ganz kurz wieder zurück fahren wir
brauchen eigentlich ich habe sogar ein
bett hier ne ne ich habe mein bett nie
vergessen ich fahr mal ganz kurz wieder
zurück zu meiner insel werde mich
schlafen legen und dann rüber fahren zum
festland denn wir brauchen wir noch mehr
tiere und da sind wir auf dem festland
angekommen meine lieben freunde dass das
was stehengeblieben war gut das
funktioniert nicht so wie ich mir das
vorstelle hier wird der ganzen
bahnstrecken warum ist es in der werbung
bietet dem gerät zurückgeschickt
wahrscheinlich weil ich da vorne auf
seine rap sonnen aktivierungs antrieb so
scheiße hier stehen ab sollten prozessor
weg kommt auch weg ich las dass aber
trotzdem hier glaube ich das nicht im
inventar habe ich platz ist jetzt
einfach mal so macht keinen sinn aber
naja ich habe ein paar toren mitgenommen
weil ich mir gedacht habe mensch im
sommer büdchen kann ich immer nur eine
person mit befördern also mich plus dann
noch irgendwie eine weitere person
deswegen dachte ich mir wenn wir jetzt
irgendwie schweinchen holen oder so dann
können wir die vielleicht in loren
setzen ich weiß nicht ob das klappt das
waren nur ein blog das war kein schwein
ich weiß auch gar nicht ob wir hier
überhaupt schweine haben ich glaube
allerdings dass hier ja relativ viel los
war eigentlich mit tieren ist herzlich
davon noch nicht so viel
allerdings können wir ja glück haben und
das ist halt das festland und hier gibt
es alles es ist genauso wie wenn du auf
einer insel wohnt freut sich auch wenn
du da sind schwein
na ja direkt erkannt habe ich doch
gerochen vorher direkt ganz viele
wir brauchen nämlich auch mehrere also
kommt mal
zum glück habe ich die karotten dabei
ich hab nur weizen mitgenommen total
vergessen dass die karotten mögen wir
brauchen ein paar mehrere denn wir
brauchen mindestens zwei und die halt
darüber zu bringen so dass die
sicherheit paaren damit wir mehr
bekommen und er schafft was das sein was
wir haben das möchte halt auf meiner
insel lassen die sollen nicht darüber
auf die tiere in sender möchte ich nicht
irgendwen verwechseln oder so deswegen
euch dreien auf jeden fall eine ganz
gute reise in den rohren gleicht das
kann doch nicht so richtig ist also
nicht zu versuchskaninchen obwohl ich
keine kaninchen sondern spannend aber es
gibt auch schon einen richtigen 1 muss
der andere der andere hotel
[Musik]
mädels
das ist gar nicht so schwer sein die
[Musik]
hochgeschwindigkeit jetzt erstmal nur
dieses eine schweinchen hierüber und
hoffe dass wir das zumindest hinbekommen
also mal ganz kurz die lupe nehmen hier
hinsetzen hier nochmal die karotte in
die hand und du perfekt du kommst hier
rein in die lore so perfekt wir müssen
nur anschieben und dann noch ein
weiteres wollen wir hatten da oben
allerdings glaube ich noch eins was wir
noch nicht geholt hatten
dementsprechend können wir den bruder
dann ein paar putts mitnehmen ich weiß
allerdings nicht mehr wo er war
da sind ja zwei schweinchen unten in die
höhle leider rein geraten dabei der
letzte müsste ich noch echt eine große
höhle hier vorne letzten müsste hier
allerdings noch irgendwo sagen ich weiß
allerdings nicht mehr wurde er sich hin
verschlagen hat da ist doch dass wir
nicht wieder hin das war noch einer
das heißt sie sollten auf jeden fall
hinkriegen ich werde euch eine ganz
kurze time jetzt einen wie ich die
rüberbringen auf meine insel
[Musik]
die schweiz aber zurückgefahren
wahrscheinlich wieder so ein kleiner
rückstau oder so ich hoffe mal dass ich
die hier vorne abfangen kann bevor die
sich auch schon wieder der antrieb
schiene hier vorne nähern also wenn man
ganz kurzen hier passt alles also wenn
ich das okay
das hat geklappt das hat auch geklappt
so jetzt kann ich ganz gut wieder nehmen
mit der karotte und rüberbringen jetzt
darf ich die nicht verwechseln mit
meiner dings ne du magst keine karotten
halt dein maul also das jetzt auf jeden
fall das schwein was wir auf unserer
insel haben und ich glaube dass ich das
jetzt erst mal ganz kurz hier rein
parken werde kommen die kannst du auch
essen die karotte hier und du bleibst du
erst mal kurz drin damit wir das nicht
verwechseln ich gehe jetzt erstmal ganz
gut schlafen kann man mal wieder hier
oben schlafen gehen ich sehe es schon
wieder kommen dass wir wieder sonne
lange folge ich glaube auch dass ich
mich jetzt mal darauf festlegen dass wir
noch nicht die chicken nuggets überholen
vom festland weil ich weiß auch gar
nicht wo die sind + ich habe einfach
keine leinen um die halt mitzunehmen
deswegen brauche ich den ohren hier na
ja ich werde mir erstmal ganz kurz zwei
boote machen eben dafür nehme ich mir
jetzt einfach 1 2 3 4 5 und ich nehme
mir beziehung ist ein anderes boot habe
ich glaube ich sogar noch aber dann kann
ich ihnen auch schon mal reinsetzen also
erstmal einen fichtenholz brot und damit
jetzt erstmal eine karotte essen spült
übrig
unglaublich aufgegessen ich es lieber
das brot und milch sprinten kann ich
werde die tiere jetzt rüber bringen
werde das mit den chicken nuggets heute
allerdings nicht mehr machen wir haben
dann schön wenn ihr das ist ja unser
schockiert sein fashion show teil
verliert also die karotte neben du
kommst mit herunter bitte mal ganz kurz
hier und dann hier das fichtenholz bot
hindu fokussiert sich bitte jetzt sofort
wieder auf meine karotte nämlich genau
jetzt und jetzt hier rein mit dir dass
ich hing fest ich endlich endlich
endlich etwas perfekt so rein hier ich
bringe dich rüber ganz große teile wie
ich den anderen augen das ist echt also
nicht das gesicht vom schwein aber insel
hier
ich bin so froh bei minecraft es ist
auch kein geheimnis mehr sind wir schon
da also erst mal ganz kurz das
schweinchen hier rüber auf die insel ich
hoffe mal dass der check dass er darüber
laufen soll sonst können wir das auf
jeden fall auch ein bisschen pushen mit
der karotte genau ob er ist schon hier
auf dem festland sind wir das
fichtenholz bötchen fahren wieder rüber
also das schwein und ein schaf ist da
wir benötigen noch ein weiteres schaf
und noch ein weiteres schwein das andere
schweine haben wir noch an unserem
bahnhof hier vorne
das schaf da müssen wir uns noch ein
anderes scharf holen auf jeden fall das
möchte ich ein khoda
hat doch ich habe eine andere idee wir
müssen allerdings erst mal ganz kurz das
schweinchen holen und ich weiß nicht wo
sich das gerade befindet also jetzt ein
katz und maus spiel auf unserer insel
hier die ist zwar nicht so groß ist
allerdings ordentlich gewachsen weil die
ganzen folgen bisher finde ich hier ist
es schon das als nicht so schwer und du
kommst auch hier vorne mit rüber auf die
insel also ganz kurz aussteigen jetzt
mal im quartier freut sich schon dass
ein kollege himmel darüber kommt also
hier auch das brot eben abgebaut wo
geht's hier hoch oft insel ich nehme
aber ganz musik heute dass er das auch
direkt zack zack
die beiden sind auf jeden fall hier die
sache ist jetzt allerdings dass sich die
beiden sicher und nicht miteinander
vermehren lassen kann
da ich noch eine karotte am start habe
ihr schild man erst mal ein bisschen das
machen wir auf jeden fall gleicht denn
meine taktik mit dem schaf wird es nun
sein dass ich mein scharf mitnehme von
meiner insel und das rüberbringen vorher
allerdings färbe so dass ich ganz genau
weiß dass er vorn ist und dass der auf
jeden fall auf meine insel gehört es
wäre auf jeden fall geben wir ihnen
jetzt auch noch nebenan auf der insel
hätten ich möchte das allerdings erstmal
hier lassen jedoch jetzt erst mal ganz
kurz das schaf werben damit wir nicht
verwechseln was gehört unternehmen was
hab ich denn überhaupt magenta können
wir beispielsweise mal nehmen ich hab
was cooles in den kommentaren gelesen
allerdings werde ich das jetzt erstmal
nicht machen das schweinchen kann ich
auf jeden fall wieder raus also kommen
perfekt wir haben das schaf ich höre es
doch hier vorne ist es also bekommt es
mal ganz kurz mit beziehungsweise vorher
werde ich mal ganz kurz das mit dem
agenten den farbstoff machen eben mit
rüber sehr gut danke schön also wir
haben das bild hier noch unten geparkt
und jetzt werde ich brauche dafür weizen
so da sind auf hat hier insel angekommen
dementsprechend auch hier noch mal ganz
kurz das büdchen abbauen direkt
allerdings wieder nehmen und hier ins
wasser setzen nicht die fackel ich will
dass ich will das so und jetzt nehmen
wir uns das weizen und wo ist unser
heißt das schiff anderer scharf das
müsste natürlich irgendwo sein so dass
sich die beiden sich miteinander hören
lassen kann
sie ist der birken baum ist der
bürgermeister wenn daisy lowe bis in
seine insel sack und pack die beiden
machen jetzt liebe wir kriegen ein
kleines baby starb und welche farbe hat
zwar schön gut also du kommst jetzt
bitte wieder mit darüber auf meine insel
einmal bitte mit kompott jetzt kommt der
bürgermeister auf mit jetzt müssen wir
gucken dass wir nur schon mit kriegen
das kleine baby dahinter kommt auch noch
mit wir müssen jetzt wirklich richtig
schnell sein und uns direkt ins brötchen
rein bewegen so dass nicht beide schafe
drin sind das haben wir allerdings
perfekt hingekriegt die beiden bleiben
bürgermeister und das kind ich hoffe
dass sie wieder zurück aufs festland
gehen und dass sie das checken
allerdings bleibt der bürgermeister noch
im wasser das kind kommt hinterher jetzt
sehen wir sie nicht mehr
also wir sind auf jeden fall wieder hier
und jetzt endlich zum letzten was wir
heute machen müssen meine lieben freunde
denn endlich muss dieser kuhstall
entfernt werden wenn ihr da pläne habe
verdi der ideen habt was wir stadt ist
kuhstalls dort hin bauen können dann
schreibst du ja nur die kommentare kommt
hoch auf die insel
wenn ihr den hab was wir hier hin bauen
können denn den wir müssen jetzt erst
mal abreißen schreibt es mir die bereits
gesagt gerne in die kommentare ich
möchte auch das habe ich zu beginn
gesagt dass eine weitere person noch
hier bleibt die ich so bisher noch nicht
gesagt habe bisher so genannt habe ich
möchte nämlich dass die normale kuh sich
hier weiterhin auf meiner insel befindet
ich weiß dass es vielleicht ein bisschen
differenzen geben wird mit der kugel
gestorben ist die wir auf unserer ortes
komm ja schon alle raus
das müsste ich mal ganz kurz hier eben
das board abbauen so dass ich hier
direkt alle in die boote einsetzen kann
das ist hier nicht auf meiner ganzen
insel jetzt laufen also ich hier noch 1
hin jetzt eben das hier nehmen so einer
muss auf jeden fall hier rein weil er
muss auch hier rein da nicht du nicht du
du nicht die normale crew will ich
nämlich auf einer insel behalten und die
jetzt sind die alle hier am rad drehen
ja wir bringen jetzt mal die beiden
hierüber jetzt sitzen die beide hier
drin ich weiß nicht ob so gute idee ist
dass wir die normale kurier lassen weil
wir damals eine kuh leider getötet haben
deswegen habe ich mir da perfekt aber
wenn wir direkt rüber bringen könnte mir
auch in die kommentare schreiben was ihr
davon haltet allerdings denke ich mir
dann habe ich halt das schaf wir haben
die bienen wir haben das schweinchen und
dann haben wir noch mal auf meiner insel
stelldichein ich ganz schön und die
pilzköpfe bringt einfach alle hier über
beziehungsweise werde ich davon auch
nachher noch eine scheren so dass wir
auch hier normale kühe und pilz für
haben also du erst mal ganz kurz ihre
auf bitte und euch jetzt noch eine ganz
kurze allerletzte team betreute wie ich
den rest der tür wohne
[Musik]
so die kühe befinden sich dort vorne auf
wird hier in selexipag ich wundervoll
aus mit dem sonnenuntergang auch hier
vorne
ich möchte zu allerletzt für die heutige
episode erstmal natürlich noch hier
alles eben schnell abbauen das soll
natürlich demnächst hier wieder aus
ihnen ganz normaler strand
beziehungsweise bin ich da wirklich
gespannt auf das was ihm in die
kommentare schreibt was wir hier hin
bauen sollen bitte nichts mit redstone
oder irgendwie sowas einfach irgendwas
kleines schönes süßes was hier
vielleicht in unserer welt passt und
dann werde ich mich da ein bisschen an
euren vorschlägen orientieren bzw werde
ich ganz kurz erst mal eben
schlafengehen passt allerdings auch ganz
gut denn ich benötige auch eine schere
um nochmal ganz kurze tieren so rüber zu
fahren und dort die pilze zu scheren
denn ich möchte dort habe ich ja gerade
schon gesagt zwei pils kühe haben bzw
auf dauer natürlich hoffentlich ein paar
mehr und allerdings auch normale küren
also ich will dort alles haben was
irgendwie normal amrum rennen ist immer
in der minecraft welt habe ich meine
schwere ich überhaupt noch
ach so ich glaube ich habe die
weggeschmissen in der höhle war ich kein
platz mehr hat dann hab ich mir gedacht
die brauche ich ja eh nicht deswegen
schere einmal kurz mitnehmen und jetzt
nochmal auch eben kurz erstmal
brauche ich glaube ich gar nichts mehr
zu sagen erst mal hier unten noch mal
eben alles abbauen auch hier die
strohballen zack und zack und jetzt hier
auch die erde weg das war wirklich sehr
schön aus auch vor allem mit der groben
erde mit dem trampel vater drehen und ok
mit dem bisschen gras und so das haben
wir schon ganz cool gemacht diesen
ganzen stall
allerdings haben wir ihnen richtig
nutzen können denn ich ernähre mich ja
in dem projekt komplett vegetarisch und
habe die kühe dann wirklich nur
gebraucht um mir zwischenzeitlich
einfach die ganzen bücher zu machen die
wir jetzt brauchen zum verzaubern und
auch für unsere zauberinsel benötigten
also jetzt hier auf jeden fall alles
wieder so ein bisschen aus wie noch in
der ersten folge ich habe mir letztens
wieder die ersten folgen angeguckt das
ist echt wahnsinn wie sich unsere insel
entwickelt hat allerdings könnt ihr mir
jetzt mal schreiben was wir hier hin
bauen sollen ich selbst glaube ich erst
mal eine fackel hin so dass wir auf
jeden fall wissen hier ist auf jeden
fall eine baustelle und jetzt noch mal
ganz kurz rüber zur tier insel ja vorne
gefahren und an der stelle würde ich
dann auch die heutigen episode minecraft
mit luca beenden wenn es euch gefallen
hat dann das geld einen daumen hoch
unter dem video hier da abonniert main
kanal wenn er noch ganz harmlos seite
und klickt auf die glocke so dass sie
eine benachrichtigung bekommt sobald ich
ein neues video hochladen youtube macht
er ja immer ab und zu spiel reinziehen
was platz angeht von daher gern
abonnieren und gerne auf die glocke
klicken
ihr seht schon ich habe gerade bei den
zweien einfach mal richtig gemacht dann
haben jetzt ja ne normale kuh und hier
und wir haben hier eine pilz co und hier
vorne eine pilz q
das heißt die beiden können sich auf
jeden fall weiter vermehren ich weiß
nicht ob wir jetzt schon wieder bock
haben der hier vorne eventuell auch sagt
dann haben wir direkt noch ein ganz
normales baby oder glaube dass ja ich
glaube dass jetzt habe ich ein kleines
baby die beiden kriegen das natürlich
auch nicht so richtig hin er ist aber
das kind von ihr dass sie irgendwie
alles ein bisschen komisch
die vermehrung in minecraft komme ich
verfüttern immer noch so ein bisschen
weit sondern die kleinen dass sie
vielleicht ein bisschen schneller groß
werden zeigt damit dass auf jeden fall
fertig haben zwei normale kirche wir
haben zwei pilze kühl hier
wir haben hier eine menge menge schöner
natur eine menge blumen ich finds
deutlich schöner hier ist somit der
blumeninsel hat wenn wir dass da hinten
so künstlich gemacht hätten
wir haben denen bürgermeister hier vorne
am start wir haben hier ein schweinchen
was wir auch noch verlieren wollten mit
den karotten nämlich mit dem anderen
schweinchen weiß gar nicht wo sich das
andere schweine sie wieder befindet
ihnen sind ist natürlich ein bisschen
größer als ich mir das eigentlich
vorgestellt hatte so kann man mit hier
vorne mit ihm hier bitte zack mischen
und dann haben wir auch noch ein kleines
neues baby schweinchen ich kann ja auch
noch ein bisschen hier karotten geben
dann wächst ja auch ein bisschen
schneller
und was natürlich die selbst noch fehlt
sind hühnchen es fehlen noch bienen also
wenn wir da noch was finden dann wird
das auf jeden fall in zukunft noch mit
dazu kommen die schäfchen hätte ich
jetzt auch noch mal ganz kurz fahren
können ich habe allerdings mein
komplettes weiterhin die tür
verschwindet ich will allerdings sagen
dass ich die heutige folge auch hier
vorne auf unserer tier insel beende ich
bin es eigentlich wirklich sehr schön
wenn ich alle rum laufen hier können wir
auch noch ein bisschen was bauen die
schildkröten siedeln sich schon an
ich freue mich ich bin bei zwei stunden
er sollte eigentlich ein kürzerer folge
werden nächste folge definitiv gesagt
aber ich alles gesagt
der blick von hier auf unserer insel
auch schön was wundervoll damit beendet
das heutige video
[Musik]